[Music]
Prince Aryan Megan Marco are the
definition of happy and in love the
newlyweds we're all smiles as they
arrived hand in hand to the wedding of
Princess Diana's niece
Celia mccorkadale and George Woodhouse
on Saturday
of course they arrived in style Harry
looked dapper in a three-piece suit and
blue tie which perfectly matched his
wife's blue and white Oscar de la Renta
dress as for the price tag on Megan's
flowy frog $5,000 the Dutchess of Sussex
completed her look with a white clutch
and fascinator plus a pair of sky-high
stilettos which proved to be tricky in
the grass Megan nearly avoided a tumble
when entering st. Andrew and Mary's
Church in Lincolnshire England good
thing for her prince's firm hold on her
hand
earlier in the week Megan made her first
solo outing with the Queen royal expert
Katie Nicol tells ET why it was so
significant it's unprecedented actually
for the Queen to have taken such a new
member of the royal family on the royal
train she didn't do that for Kate and I
think you only needed to look at their
body language and the warmth between the
two of them to see just how how warmly
embraced Megan has been by the Queen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]